but like what okay so we went across
like how many states do we go in America
again I'm in a cross or like a
drive-through or like stopped in oh
stopped in yeah like 30 maybe 40 35.
what was that no not that many no maybe
30 30. I'd say yeah 25 to 30. yeah
because it was weird because I was like
talking to Sydney I was like I think
I've been to more States than you have
now yeah
we've probably traveled more of the US
than most people yeah yeah I I actually
downloaded an app which is like you can
mark off like which states you've been
to in the US I've been to exactly 25
States like 50 of the US yeah and I'm
like that's more than most Americans I'm
like that's pretty cool but obviously we
only spent a day there so it's like yeah
I don't count the ones we drove yeah
yeah I think like a day is enough to get
like a Vibe no I agree but not enough to
like know everything about a place but
no okay it was like enough for me to get
a Vibe out where I would where would
like possibly like to go back in the
future maybe yes top three three places
in the US you want to go
um on this Tour on this tour okay
first place is easy for me Nashville
Tennessee
that would be in my top three for sure
like Nashville was super weird for me
because if you're not from the US you no
one really like knows about it there's
no some musical people are from there
yeah you just know if some new musical
people know about it uh are from there
sorry but like no one really like talks
about Nashville but it was like one of
the most active and happening cities we
went to on our tour I think uh because
there's this strip on Nashville uh and I
went it's called the strip it's called
The Strip it was like I think it's like
their Broadway or something like that
um and I went there on a Tuesday at 3
P.M and it felt like I just walked into
a music festival there's this strip in
Nashville that is like playing that has
live music in every bar 24 7. that's
pretty cool yeah it's [ __ ] insane
um and also like the city was like very
chill it's like in the South as well so
you get like Southern Hospitality which
I was like one thing I discovered him
was good the chicken that was awesome
and and and it was only one of uh four
cities that voted bone and chicken as
Superior so what isn't there to like
about Nashville Tennessee [ __ ]
awesome City I like natural good chicken
all right so what's number two and three
then gone number two
is it is it just on this tour just on
this tour just on the stool yeah that
you discovered okay I don't know if it's
gonna be a cop-out but I already enjoy
Toronto Canada as well
the only Canadian stuff we went to no I
really really enjoy Toronto and I'm
already like planning to go back they
would sit here actually I like to write
that too but I'm not including it on the
list yeah you know what you said
[Applause]
I went there on this tour where's number
it was number three then number three
I'll have to think about it
well for me it's like in no particular
order Nashville Tennessee was sick as
[ __ ] yeah uh I really like Denver
Colorado Okay um just because like it
kind of has like it weirdly reminded me
a lot of Melbourne in the sense that
it's like especially like in Denver like
in the city everything is like you know
it's it's built up and it's compact but
like there's a lot of things to do in a
really small vicinity like you could
walk Denver if you wanted to and like
explore it and stuff like that it was
really [ __ ] dope
um and then I really like Seattle I was
going to say Seattle was sick as [ __ ]
because I I I remember going there I
loved like I love the culture of Seattle
yeah it's kind of like it's it's kind of
like a good mix
um it's like a good mix of like West
Coast yeah without like but I think like
felt like their own flavor than say San
Fran and La yeah the we went down to
those uh like famous uh markets yeah
yeah
um and like I don't know about you guys
but like it gave me like a weirdly
European Vibe yeah like in like a weird
way like it was clearly still like
American right but like the markets
themselves and like kind of the
atmosphere and the vibe of just that
little area like near the water was very
European I'm like this is cool I really
need I will say though I I probably
wouldn't include Seattle on the list
because I've been to Seattle several
times before because I have family there
um I really really like the city but we
went when we went there weather was
perfect yeah weather was perfect all
right I've been to Seattle before and it
was raining basically every day and it
was rain I [ __ ] despised rain okay
I don't want the rain oh another place I
actually quite enjoyed which I've been
to before but this time around I had a
really really fun time was uh Chicago
yeah I was gonna say so my top three in
no particular order Chicago's probably
on there so it was fun I hate to say
this to piss off New York people but
it's like New York it better
um I know that's gonna that's gonna
trigger so many more people
um it kind of had like all the cool
aspects of New York uh at least at least
the central part yeah I didn't go to the
scary parts yeah yeah
um but the the town like the downtown
and the center of it was amazing I
thought sick and the food was awesome
yeah
um except people kept trying to sell me
drugs that kind of sucked oh yeah of
course Chicago Seattle for sure yeah
that was [ __ ] awesome that's such a
good time yeah Seattle there's a city is
so cool yeah it's laid out is awesome
yeah a really really walkable again it
reminds me of Melbourne great food I had
awesome [ __ ] food Seattle with the
seafood I had was just so good had king
crab so good yeah so good actually oh go
for it and then third City that's a
tough one to put on I'd say I actually
really enjoyed Austin Yeah Austin Austin
was right I I was like because I you
know I it's weird
actually like I I noticed that if I like
my tier list of likes American cities we
went to a lot of like the top tier ones
are the ones that were easier easy to
scoot around in I noticed I noticed the
correlation of ease of like ease of
ability to scoot around in with the
e-scooters and my likability of that
City I will show I've really I've been
there before but I really like
Minneapolis I wish we got more time
there yeah yeah Minneapolis is like a
Vibe we get this really cool Diner yeah
I forgot what it was called owls
breakfast so [ __ ] good and that vibe
in that Diner was so fun everyone the
staff they were sick yeah I was asking
questions they were like so you really
eat beans on toast yes yes we do you
can't get it here though yeah I I don't
want it here don't want it yeah it was
so good I love Minneapolis which of
course yeah I really like this phone I
really like the Midwest Midwest Shame
about your Winters though as well
[Applause]
oh man and of course it was I we had to
be there on my [ __ ] boat
I felt like we were going to get points
if I boarded up Windows like there was
no one no one in Cleveland Ohio yeah I
I've been told that Columbus Ohio was
much better and it was much more lively
but Cleveland shocked yeah yeah because
I remember I remember when we woke up
for our Ohio show and uh you know
sometimes we have to stop for gas or
something uh in Midway from like you
know driving to each City I wake up I
look out the window and I turn to one of
the staff members I'm like so when are
we going to the venue
and he points to like this empty parking
lot and he was just like this is the
venue we are here now and I was just
like what it was rough it was rough one
thing we learned from this tour about
America is that for some reason everyone
is haze Ohio for some reason uh even
Ohio hates Ohio
no one likes Ohio yeah yeah we we had uh
we had one of the questions in our live
show was like what is the one stage you
don't want to be transported or Isa
guide to and uh out of 23 shows 21
states voted Ohio as like the worst
state in America including Ohio
including Ohio and I'm like what the
[ __ ] you guys dude it was only San
Francisco and Portland and they voted at
number two yeah so you know it's not
much better we had how the US
collectively came together to hate Ohio
yeah because like I think like
everyone's Minds you know outside of
America it's like the worst state is
Florida right because you just hear
about it so much and it's so
sensationalized with like Florida man
stuff like that but I guess like the the
the truth the the True Villain at the
end of it all the secret Villa nothing
like once you defeat Florida who's the
secret boss at the end it's Ohio baby
after the credits roll there's a final
boss you have to find yeah so that was
interesting but uh you know yeah after
our stop in Cleveland I'm like yeah you
know what don't blame them it's pretty
bad